all right the planned ground Invasion as
John just mentioned of Gaza has been
delayed since Friday but why well the
Jerusalem Post says it's because of the
IDF hasn't done anything like this in
decades and rushing in unprepared could
be a very big mistake so what Intel
could they be seeing that's giving them
pause here now to discuss the
possibilities John Ratliff former
Director of National Intel under
President Trump John I know we don't
know for sure but what do you suspect is
going on
here
uh I suspect that the Israelis are
balancing you know responding quickly
versus uh responding smartly Laura
everyone knows that there's going to be
a ground incursion by the Israelis into
Gaza and it's sort of like you know if
you're playing chess and you're telling
everyone ahead of time where your Rook
is going on the chessboard your
adversaries know uh and will make plans
accordingly and in this case you know
what Israel has to has to deal with is
they have multiple adversaries that are
now planning in the case of Hamas the
challenges are you have a you know a a
group that is has already been willing
to disregard the you know International
uh Warfare principle of Distinction
meaning that they're uh they're willing
to um uh treat civilians and uh
combatants the same and hide among them
and use hostages now up to possibly 250
as human Shields and they understand
that as the number of civilians grow
Israel knows that um the support that
they have in the International Community
and even within the US will fade so they
they need to plan for that and as John
Roberts just talked about the challenge
is that they have an even more lethal
opponent uh to the North in Hezbollah
you know unlike Hamas Hezbollah has a
sophisticated fighting force of 100,000
people uh they have 130,000 Precision
guided rockets and drones that have the
capability of overwhelming uh Iran's I
mean Israel's uh primary defense system
the the Iron Dome and so you know I
think that the Israelis are are are
balancing these many challenges and
making sure that when they move that
they they they uh they move in the most
strategically smart way possible right
it's pretty hard though isn't because
there are two competing factors here the
element of surprise is lost Ian there is
you can't have an elements of surprise
when you're obviously concerned about
civilian losses unlike Hamas which
indiscriminately kills uh women and
children but the Israel uh is actually
concerned about that right so you lose
the element of surprise Hamas knows
you're coming meanwhile Hezbollah to the
North and the Lord knows what else is
going to come into
play right I mean Israel's willing to to
do what we would do which is you know to
try and fight within you know the the
the Norms of um International Warfare
and your adversaries are willing to
disregard those and it puts you at that
disadvantage and they know that you're
coming um and so you know it is a
tremendous Challenge and I think that's
what that delay is uh is is uh
attributable to I want to John I want to
get into the the value of our Intel
going to Israel at this point because
there have been some questions about
whether information that we had about a
potential attack ever made its way to
Israel whether we had sufficient uh
Intel on this so there is some new
reporting tonight that is claiming that
the CIA Intel on this uh Hamas attack
never reached Biden saying that they
were dismissed as routine and US Intel
agencies were focused on other intern
threats primarily China Russia Iran and
that this strategic shift in priorities
may have contributed to a lack of
attention given to the Intelligence on
Hamas so the CIA might be trying to
cover its you know what John but they're
saying you know we we said we saw this
was going to come and they were
distracted with other priorities it
reminds me of what happened before 911 I
mean it's similar similar
concerns well you know I have talked
with folks Within the Intel Community
presently um that have indicated that
unfortunately the Biden Administration
may have redirected or retasked some um
intelligence assets away from the Middle
East uh to Ukraine and I I don't know
whether that that is the case but uh but
I do know this you know Laura we we both
want the United States to be the the the
Ally that Israel needs right now but
what's inescapable is the fact that you
know National Security adviser Jake
Sullivan was on National TV doing a not
so humble brag two weeks ago saying that
the Middle East has never been quieter
and he spent less time on that on those
issues than any of his predecessors in
the last 20 years and and that is a
whiff of Epic Proportions because
obviously you know just uh two weeks
later you know the Israelis people have
suffered the worst atrocity since the
Holocaust and so you know the the role
that the US should be playing Laura is
that our best uh intelligence Enterprise
our human intelligence our signals
intelligence our geospatial intelligence
should be working hand and glove with
the Israelis to support them in what
they need but I think there are real
questions about our own intelligence
assets and capabilities as directed by
this Administration well I'm going to
get into that in the angle the
competence of of the United States to
even be involved here at some level but
John uh invaluable Insight thank you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else